BEING DOWN 0-2, GIANNIS HOPES TO
MAKE IT FIVE.
>> ANY ADDED EXCITEMENT KNOWING
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO PLAY IN THE
NBA FINALS IN FRONT OF THE HOME
FANS FOR THE FIRST TIME?
DOES IT FEEL LIKE IT IS
SOMETHING STARTING A LITTLE BIT
OVER AGAIN THAT YOU ARE HOME?
>> I'M JUST HERE NOT TO GET
FINED.
I'M JOKING, I'M JOCKING.
-- I'M JOKING.
IT HAS BEEN 50 YEARS SINCE WE
PLAYED ONE HERE IN MILWAUKEE.
FOR SURE IT IS GOING TO BE
EXCITING.
>> ERIC IN THE BACK.
>> GIANNIS, FOR YOU IN THAT GAME
AS YOU GET TO 42 YOU HIT A
NUMBER OF THOSE MID-RANGE
JUMPERS, THOSE TURNAROUNDS YOU
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON.
DO YOU WILL LIKE YOU HAVE HAD A
BREAK-THROUGH WHERE YOU ARE
FEELING MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT SHOT?
IT FELT MAYBE DURING THE NETS
SERIES YOU GOT TO IT A COUPLE
MORE TIMES.
WHAT ARE YOU FEELING WITH THAT
SHOT AND HOW YOU ARE USING IN
RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M MORE COMFORTABLE NOT TO
THINK ABOUT IT.
NOW THAT YOU SAID IT I MIGHT
MISS THEM TOMORROW BECAUSE OF
YOU.
I'M FEELING MORE COMFORTABLE,
TRYING TO GO DOWNHILL.
SOMETIMES GUYS STAY IN FRONT OF
ME AND CREATE A WALL THAT I
CAN'T GET IN THE PAINT SO YOU
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT OR WAYS TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
THERE IS PASS THE BALL, MAYBE A
JUMP SHOT, OR GET TO A SPOT AND
SHOOT OVER THEM.
BUT YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO BE EFFECTIVE.
SOMETIMES YOU ARE GOING TO MAKE
THEM, SOMETIMES YOU ARE GOING TO
MISS THEM, BUT YOU HAVE TO KEEP
BEING AGGRESSIVE.
MY MINDSET IS ALWAYS TRY TO GET
DOWNHILL AND MAKE THE RIGHT
PLAY, THE RIGHT DECISION.
IF IT IS A PASS OR SCORING.
BUT SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THOSE SHOTS.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP THE DEFENSE
GUESSING.
I FEEL COMFORTABLE, AND
HOPEFULLY MOVING FORWARD I WILL
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE IN THOSE
SHOTS AND BE MORE EFFECTIVE.3
>> I HAVE TWO.
WHY WERE YOU WORRY ABOUT GETTING
FINED?
GIANNIS: A FOOTBALL PLAYER,
MARSHON LYNCH SAID THAT IN HIS
MEDIA DAY.
DO I HAVE TO DO THIS?
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME HERE, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME IN THE NBA
FINALS AND I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN
GET FINED AND THEY WILL SEND ME
HOME.
>> THE MORE SERIOUS QUESTION,
WHEN YOU DECIDED TO COMMIT TO
THE EXTENSION, HOW DID YOU TELL
THE BUCKS?
WHO DID YOU CALL OR TEXT?
GIANNIS: MAN, I DON'T REMEMBER.
PROBABLY TALKED WITH JON HORST,
I THINK.
I THINK IT WAS HIM, CALLED HIM
AND TOLD HIM.
YEAH, YOU KNOW, I'M STAYING.
AND THEN JUST HANG UP THE PHONE
AND WENT ABOUT M